how's it going bros my name is Pierre -
PAH we're playing inside part three this
game is so [ __ ] good
it's amazing what happened it froze
there it is oh my god I'm so immersed by
this game check out part 1 if you're on
part 3 for some reason without watching
the other ones or just check out the
damn game yourself it's so [ __ ] cool
I've done this part already let's do it
really quick here we go okay we're back
in action oh my god oh my god I didn't
know it ow why did you just jump down we
got to be fast - no I slid down oh my
god there we go got to be fast here
there it is oh wow there's a hatch over
there okay we know what we got to do
this is oh god crazy
oh my god how long does it we have to go
in there right
go go oh my god Jesus are we gonna go in
the Train perhaps I think we're going on
the train it seems like the game is
insinuating between man jumping perhaps
we're going down here I have really
strong legs I gotta hand it to my son I
got a leg Ajay Singh hilarious boots you
did it what are you doing man sometimes
it's a little weird that you can't
change the camera angle I kind of want
to know what I'm about to drop into
let's try swinging it love it yeah I
don't think it's worth it okay I guess
since we heard the water dripping I
should have been proof enough all right
let's keep making it out of here so it
seems like there's this upper class or
something of people that controls the
rest of the population and we're the
ones that kind of broke away from that
that's Oliver that I would guess so far
they're gonna be electricity in the
water oh there's dogs over there that's
why we're sneaking right now
they're still out looking for us because
we broke free somehow
oh no they run away man they sounds so
scary I didn't expect water
let's go away from the light skin is
very much dark like limbo was as well oh
no [ __ ] you get it within the water boy
I did not expect that
Jesus oh I was like I'm fine I made it I
don't know what the [ __ ]
[Music]
it literally it's [ __ ] chewing my
body out let's see how far we can swim
the dog is after us oh [ __ ] oh we won't
go under the surface though it's stupid
doggy this is how you're supposed to do
it oh my god it's gonna chase us now
though
oh my god
[ __ ] the dyes no more
Oh God
we don't have much time [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] this [ __ ] dogs
man
Oh God
let me coming back terrifying terrifying
the dog hate me so much
come on come on in stupid evil Darger's
we can only do one at a time not more at
the race
oh my god they gone me did you not just
kick them got it
oh I could go through I didn't have to
pull them all okay nice [ __ ] you
I'm just gonna keep running just in case
you never know what's gonna happen what
it's this place it feels a bit I was
supposed to take light it was night what
a great way to die thanks game thanks
play dead
Thanks it feels a bit half-life II I
don't know why am I wrong
do you feel it - it's brilliant puzzles
I really really enjoy it I hope you're
enjoying watching and like I said this
is kind of game I like I don't want to
spoil this for anyone if you feel like
you want to play the game by all means
what is that that's a submarine that guy
just came from a [ __ ] submarine
okay now they're going inside oh god
they're gonna see me right
we're gonna take the submarine yes oh my
god
where this what this is so cool
why am I going in at seminary I do not
know it's the coolest thing ever
absolutely I'm so curious about the
universe and what's happening inside
this game not the actual universe the
universe is lame
how do we open this we have to swim out
do you think that's what we had to do
what does that button do I did something
and now what is this dear what is this
dude boy boosts it's a booster oh it
worked
oh okay let's do another boost whoa
hello darkness my old friend
this is spider from limbo is gonna pop
out I know him that's [ __ ] disgusting
oh my god
and so immersed I want to be part of
this halt horrible melancholic universe
[Music]
except I'd be dead like on the stage one
the only thing that this game is missing
is Nate's hair I gotta say it's still
like a little disappointing
right there's a wall here let's go down
it seems very unsafe what happened here
why did we flood so much clearly there's
a lot of buildings under water
what happened what went wrong
seems like a terrible idea I didn't
really do it did it
right sir
[ __ ] window though I suppose we could
swim through do you want to try that is
that a bad idea let's do it that would
make sense although I don't want to
leave my little friend you know you know
what I want a better grasp of air is
that what you say grasp of air probably
night okay we're on the other side but I
miss my submarine already at least I
feel safer here from dogs that is unless
there's dogs and submarines then we're
[ __ ]
I don't think that's a thing yet unless
this is like spy movie - or some [ __ ]
dogs fight and look they're talking it's
a rope there let's go up I'm Tarzan
right now write some of the lockers that
looks like it could crack in a second
I'm not gonna stay around to find out
thanks game thank you of course
see this this game is it's not about
dying it's by learning we just died but
we also just learned something you know
what I mean oh [ __ ]
I just became
you know the guy could just move to the
[ __ ] left the guy is stuck in one
dimension it would be kind of funny if
they we need to open this hatch right I
don't think we're fast enough to run to
the edge but we might be hey let's try
it
hey how about that let's just try and be
real [ __ ] fast no oh there might be
hope guys there might be [ __ ] it up oh
we're gonna get squished stay down stay
down stay down
whoa that was cool that was real [ __ ]
cool okay we did it oh good I feel good
man yeah we're [ __ ] good it's really
satisfying it makes you feel smarter
than you are or less dumb I guess it's
the right term whoa where are we this is
an Ewok [ __ ] man no one's been here in a
while why they're generators that are
you hugging the generator dude stop stop
hugging to generate a man that's can we
climb this we can't let's keep going
all right it goes down here apparently I
can't [ __ ] see I think that's the
point here is the wall who put a wall
there
guess they want to keep the citizens in
maybe that's what happened
I don't know the game won't tell me okay
it seems like we can wiggle this No oh
hello oh come on I jumped off alright
let's do it I'm ready
[ __ ] it I can't die yeah I knew I would
do that no problem
alright we're up here now and we're
moving in this axis direction what whoa
whoa I think we're gonna have to swing
across here right yeah there's a hole
there I see it now huh one more for
safety I'm pressing some hard on the
buttons
Thanks Bucci huh I'm totally ruing the
beautiful beautiful colors [ __ ] xbox
is that what we wear with a submarine I
think we just saved our submarine oh
there are Sea Dogs I knew it hurry hurry
I knew it I call that [ __ ] where's my
sub me Missy Missy Missy go up dude
hurry there's sea dogs not thank god
we're safe probably not we're definitely
not saving can we even get across oh you
think this will work how much you're
gonna bet this is gonna work
I'll bet against alright it will work I
just need to do it properly I'm Mike
Mike Mike Mike Mike Mike come on man
come on yeah of course that's that's
that's what do you invent for a
submarine that's everyone knows that's
how they work right now what we got to
go on oh we can break this yeah this is
creepy it's a locked door there
something here perhaps
maybe we can go down here
No
it's our reason we can move this now
seemed like a bad idea we're gonna hook
ourself or something what about this
door that simple alright
so I think we're gonna have to swim down
from here but I think our submarine
needs to be in the right place while we
do what do we want it
keep looking on me
before we do anything rash
okay all right here's where we exit huh
just hope there's no Sea Dogs how does
the electricity working down here I
don't know don't look at me like that
it's not like I know okay swimming down
oh god I'm gonna run out of breath
okay
what did I just do guys
I see the Beast I see the police
everyone I see the fittest did I do it
was that it I just have to have it maybe
let's try it hey hey that was it
[ __ ] I'm smart I mean come on I gotta
Pat myself a little bit on the back
sometimes what is that a mermaid dude
get oh god I'm dead why are they so a
kid what happened there we gotta keep
keep lining it otherwise it's gonna
attack us
that's a chair a chair no no
no [ __ ] off
No all right you can take your long ass
hair and [ __ ] up right serve some humans
mutated maybe these are experiments or
some [ __ ] I don't know
no one knows
I don't like it that's all I know
all right I don't like it
Oh God
talk that thing is creepy this is a
puzzle or doing a puzzle right now
[Music]
I just don't know how to do it maybe we
can trap it yeah we can trap it alright
that's what we're doing
we're gonna have to trick it to swim out
No okay this is it now you stay it stay
there all right young lady with your
creepy eyes here pop the poets it's
gonna have to [ __ ] you up [ __ ] that's
right that's how it's done
[ __ ] mermaids whatever the hell that was
I feel great now I feel fantastic
hey hey damn it Megan did I just die no
this is one of those No whoa oh god it's
gonna come it's gonna come it's kind of
calm it's gonna come it's gonna come
this is not the last we've seen a
mermaid oh god [ __ ] the water [ __ ] the
water I'm out he's out he's out relax
max and all cool and all shootin some
mullets goodbye somebody thank you
what is that red light in the distance
oh my god
this is so cool I am so impressed by
this game I love it love love love it
okay we're going towards a door another
giant a structure okay can we push it oh
my god I think I was no I'm okay
whoa hey dude how are you not so good
how would you feel if I open I don't
think I'm strong enough I need to wake
him up to help me okay how can we wake
us up a sleeping man who's standing up
and sleeping have you guys ever stood up
and slept and done it once in the shower
don't need to paint that picture don't
worry I'm not gonna
that's where the sounds it really
reminds me a lot of half-life 2 without
all them aliens and murder how do we
have you what is it I can't see I pull
it up or I don't think he knows either
another sleepwalker huh sorry but why
did I just do
there needs to be 19 of us on this
platform
how how ok no problem ok well now this
is going so maybe we all this thing
[Music]
and up we're going of course of course
don't you worry I know what I'm doing
alright looks like there's a bigger
puzzle here do you think we can jump
across I don't think so but you don't
know until you try it
no there's no way let's check here's
then 19 we need 19 well 18 technically
perhaps even 17 oh my god
hey there's a lot of fellas here y'all
can help me out
I just open this now never mind then
sorry gated dude's doesn't look like I
can do [ __ ] I wonder if they are like
dead or alive I can't really tell are
the ones snoring so maybe they're like
in this state or something
we're going to the bottom to the bottom
looks like someone peed on this thing
Oh what we're really going down we
first what is this is it hot
it smells like avocado ice is delight
okay I mean I'm not nearly strong enough
I need to be able to control people to
do all these things
and I can't reach that thing this is
definitely a bigger puzzle
let's check the roulette the last sign
and what we got we need some people
helping us what is this
hello disappointed we never went on the
train yeah alright [ __ ] it
going down as Christ Jesus Christ Oh
excellent I keep running into more dead
ends for more fellows how do you guys
have there it is there's a helmet now I
know where to god oh my god how do we
get there oh boy
don't die dude again seem like it this
guy has a tough life man how is how do i
how do i keep running into some of the
dead ends
I might doing it right or wrong I feel
like I'm doing it wrong but let's keep
swinging got good momentum we've got
this I'm not gonna [ __ ] this up just cuz
I'm impatient not today here we go Tosh
enjoy why is there tripod here with
lights that's what I want to know
I have no theory as to why this universe
is like it is maybe they're using the
people as mining or whatever
make sense Oh God oh this is weird are
they gonna carry me they're gonna carry
me onwards are they just following me
they're just kind of following me aren't
they
I am behind minded this is cool
all right guys lift me up thanks guys
appreciate it
all right guys follow me now I'm not
trapped anymore oh wow this is really
like aha I have the Hat y'all better
listen to me he can't miss it yeah you
can come along let's play
[ __ ] yeah it's a party gets to join
the guy that everyone invites cuz they
feel sorry for him come on Rupert you're
part of the team now now we're not gonna
go up yet we're gonna check out the
trend the Train of course come on lads
ooh actually you got yeah you guys know
what yeah I don't even have to tell you
yeah strange it's like they know what to
do is it's not like they're stupid but
they literally just follow orders okay
we're not jumping down there there we
are going through here
No are we supposed to go what's down
there
I don't know
are the guys following me they are
following me down there oh they are they
are there I see them so if I grab no
perhaps if I jump down here they will
catch me thanks guys good [ __ ] job
you fired alright guys let help me help
of course of course I should see
okay
you do need to try and tell me I love
them they're so cute and helpful this is
such a good puzzle okay I think we're
gonna wake up the guy that's outside so
we go down here oh no okay
and now they push it all right careful
guys I don't want to die all right
I just dot I did just die when I said
that okay so I think these guys have to
cut up I have to wait here there it is I
was being a little greedy
created a little faster thanks guys
appreciate it
wait there I'll be right back all right
we can climb here I love my hat it's a
great hat it's a great look where am I
going now this area is huge because you
know we're gonna go back to the nineteen
number later their chest what is this
but is yes oh it's one of these and up
we go
well that was [ __ ] wasn't it or if I
jump at the same time what am I missing
here maybe I need to go underneath it oh
of course
oh hey guys welcome to the party
now follow me yeah I like your hat
let's go [ __ ] yeah you're free not
really man let's finish this [ __ ] it
let's finish this puss on I know we can
do it it's a big as possible I like it's
huge
in fact hi guys I brought some France
it's gonna be the best party ever follow
me follow me everything is all right I
be the one who tuck you in it neck I'm
not gonna talk to anyone of you in the
night all right
are they sleeping listen to
now they're just grunting I thought they
were sleeping
[Music]
all right we're going up no don't
guys I'm trying - guys guys please
that's thank you Rupert I don't like how
you're looking at him oh thank you I am
The King
all right y'all bet it stop don't touch
me
now we're going neat you know we're
going this back sorry Rupert I just
knocked that guy over all right we
should be able to save these guys now
come on
maybe we should push them up sorry guys
I don't know if this will hurt a night
that probably hurt a lot yeah they're
fine sorry I guess being a little [ __ ]
head girls like
I'm almost done again I promised the
bros I would finish this puzzle all
right now throw me there oh my god it
worked all right guys I'll be right back
sleep your head
oi wake the [ __ ] up this one's not
working wait dude come on wake up Jesus
Christ time to go to work
it's me before I make a video every day
guys I found one oh [ __ ] maybe that will
wake him up catch me
thank you who touched my ass who did it
okay I think we should I guess it
doesn't matter if they're dead or not
the body count should count that's a big
job
my name I came here not that many to be
honest I expected more I'm recording
you're being super rude Edgar super guy
they're dead
well oh they're fine hey how about that
alright how many are were you we need to
wake this guy up guys this isn't party
could you oh yeah these guys can lift it
up alright buddy how many are in here
just one come on anymore ayyy this
puzzle keeps going oh my god
throw me hey we got more coming hey guys
alright how do we do this
how do we do this almost
this is it there it is
welcome to the party guys how many are
we now well you guys worried about me
[ __ ] off all right come on we got a
party to plan now this is a party y'all
better not slack off or you're not
getting paid actually you're not getting
paid regardless I like your skin tone
white power
sorry that was a bad joke
[Music]
come on guys
it's gonna be a great party I have a
great feeling about it I don't know how
many we are let's let's check how many
where I should be there should be
someone sleeping here
oh oh just two more
just two more how about that
okay let's bring you sky on I guess we
did it all right guys it's been real
see you later oh my god this place is
breaking apart
oh my god no my hat
we're gonna have that in that episode
there if you bros enjoyed please leave a
like we're about halfway through the
game and I will promise you I'll see you
tomorrow with a new one if you leave
like thank you so much for watching I'll
see you both tomorrow I'll have to take
this dog app I guess breakfast I can't I
can't played it
I can't oh it keeps happening
I'm crying it's so beautiful
[Music]